[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains de nos collègues nous ont fait
part de leur surprise quand ils ont
voulu louer une voiture récemment ça
nous a donné l'idée de vérifier parce
que marie-claude les prix ont fortement
augmenté oui et j'ai été surprise aussi
en regardant combien ça coûte maintenant
louer une voiture pour une journée
seulement la fin de semaine donc j'ai
pas de comparatif de sortie des prix
approximatif parce que ça peut varier
d'une journée à l'autre d'un locataire à
l'autre mais vous voyez septembre 2021
maintenant quand j'ai fait quelques
recherches autour de 100 dollars par
jour ça inclut les taxes mais pas les
sens donc vous devez faire le plein
septembre 2020 ya une enquête autour de
60 dollars septembre 2019 ya deux ans 35
ça vraiment grimper de façon importante
son secteur qui était frappé de plein
fouet par la pandémie l'absence de
touristes de fait très mal et pour
pallier cette absence de revenus les
locataires ont vendu une partie de leur
flotte donc maintenant il manque de
voitures il va en racheter mais ne
seront pas vraiment disponibles à ce
moment pénurie de semi conducteurs a eu
des problèmes aussi dans certaines
usines qui vendent aux locateurs et puis
2,8 main d'oeuvre là aussi pour
l'entretien mécanique c'est ce que m'a
expliqué l'association des locataires de
voiture donc si vous voulez une autre
solution parce que vous trouvez ça trop
cher vous pouvez vous tourner par
exemple vers communauto ses sorties les
prix environ 50 $ plus taxes et ça c'est
sans abonnement si vous avez un forfait
c'est moins cher ça inclut le
kilométrage et l'essence dans ce cas là
la lecture aux qui est un partage auto
partage de véhicules vous louez en
particulier en fait oui on ne sait pas
partir de 40 dollars ça dépend de la
voiture les conditions si le kilométrage
qui inclut l'assurance n'est pas incluse
et vous allez devoir aller chercher le
véhicule là où il se trouve donc sa
demande certaines recherches et vous
nous avez fait un petit test pour savoir
combien coûte un déplacement posons
montréal québec pour la farine solide
pour voir si vous voulez aller vous
promener dans le vieux-québec une fin de
semaine prendre une voiture ou un autre
moyen 30 contre souvenu le contrat bruit
qui répondait à montréal on nous voir à
montréal donc si vous louez une voiture
c'est au tour de 200 $ pour faire le
voyage pour la fin de semaine comme une
haute autour de 150 $ qu'on est plus les
taxes et dont les frais l'autobus 135 $
par personne oui oui aller à 2 pour
calculer le double les trains 180
dollars par personne et c'est un peu
plus long aussi le train comme dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut lire tranquillement
oui exactement
on me dit du côté des locateurs que ça
devrait se calmer au cours des prochains
mois avec l'arrivée de nouvelles
voitures m'ont garanti pas si les primes
on dit merci marie claude germain prix
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit